ودمرت اكثر من نصف شبكه الطاقه في هذا
البلد وقصفت اكثر من 700 مستشفى و 26 الف
مدرسه واختطفت على الاقل 6000 من الاطفال
الاوكرانيين بعضهم لا يتجاوزوا بضعه اشهر
واعادتهم
الى روسيا
لكن الروح في اوكرانيا تبقى غير مهزومه بل
انها اكثر قوه وعزما من اي وقت مضى عندما
اطلقت اوكرانيا العمليه المضاده التي سمحت
لاعاده وضع اليد على جزء من اراضيها ارسل
الرئيس بوتين 300 الف شخص ورحل مزيد من
الاطفال
وكذلك اطلق مجموعه فاجنر ومرتزقه ارتكبوا
فضائح من افريقيا وشرق الاوسط والان في
اوكرانيا
طبعا ليست هذه القصه الكامله عن هذه السنه
تمت قصه الشعب الاوكراني
عدد القوات الروسيه كان يفوق عدد القوات
الاوكرانيه ولكن الاوكرانيين وقفوا
مدافعين عن حقهم بتقرير مستقبلهم وقفوا في
وحده وتضامن فيما يتعاملون مع هذا العدوان
مدرسون اعطوا دروس في
للاطفال وعملوا على اعاده اتاحه الطاقه
وتضامن الجيران لاطعام الروعه في هذه قصه
كذلك كيف ان الاسره الدوليه وقفت وتضامنت
معظم الدول الاعضاء مرات عديده ادانه
انتهاكات روسيا لمثاق الامم المتحده
ومحاولتها لوضع اليد والاستيلاء على اراضي
اوكرانيه يوم امس 140 دوله في الجمعيه
العامه صوتت لصالح قرار يعيد التاكيد على
المبادئ الاساسيه المتعلقه بسياده وسلامه
اراضي اوكرانيا ويندد بالفضاء التي
ترتكبها روسيا ويعبر عن التضامن كذلك
والتائيه لسلام عادل وشامل حسب ميثاق
الامم المتحده
عندما حاول الرئيس بوتين ان يستخدم الجوع
اداه ويؤدي الى استيعار ازمه غذائيه هي
الاخطر ردت الاسره الدوليه سريعا
منذ الاجتماع الذي عقد فيما يحول هذا
الموضوع قامت 100 دوله بالاعلان مجموعه من
الالتزامات للتخفيف من حده الجوع من خلال
مساعي الامين العام وكذلك تركيا جاءت
مبادره تصير الحبوب من خلال البحر الاسود
الى
ايصال هذه الحبوب والتخفيف من كلاتها
للعالم والان فيما تحاول موسكو مره جديده
ان تقود ذلك يجب ان نضمن
توسيع هذه المبادره
وعندما حاول الرئيس بوتين ان يستخدم
الطاقه اداه زدنا من التزويد عبر العالم
وذلك حتى تمكن الناس من ان يحظوا بالتدفئه
في خلال الشتاء وكذلك للحد من الاتكال على
طاقه الروسيه
عانت اوكرانيا اشد المعاناه طبعا من الحرب
روسيا ولكن كل دوله استشعرت بهذه المعاناه
الا ان الدول عبر العالم مازالت تقف الى
جانب اوكرانيا لاننا نقر جميعا بانه لو
تخلينا عن اوكرانيا اليوم فنحن نتخلى عن
ميثاق الامم المتحده بحد ذاته وعن القواعد
التي تضمن اماننا جميعا وسلامه
ان الاستيلاء على الاراضي بالقوه وان محو
حدود دوله اخرى وان استهداف مدنيين في
الحروب وان حروب العدوان كلها غير مقبول
بها ولو لم ننتصر لهذه المبادئ فهذا يحدث
الى عالم
يسيطر فيه القوي على الضعيف والعالم الذي
انشات هذه المنظمه لوضع حد لها واعضاء هذا
المجلس عليهم مسؤوليه خاصه الا وهي الا
نعود الى هذا الشكل من العالم ويمكن ان
نقوم بذلك من خلال سوبر ثلاث اولا يجب ان
نضغط باتجاه سلام عادل وجامل طبعا التوقع
ان دولا عديده سوف تطالب بالسلام اليوم
ولكن لا احد يريد السلام اكثر من الشعب
الاوكراني